whether you're healthy or you're sick
pretty much everyone in this country is
suffering thanks to this pandemic but
there's one big exception one group
that's thriving and it's not just
private equity people it's criminals in
New York City the mass closure of stores
has resulted in predictably a massive
surge in break-ins according to New York
City Police Department burglaries of
commercial properties are up 75 percent
compared to last year burglaries of
bodegas and supermarkets are up 400% if
you're a criminal wanted try if they
catch you New York's bail law means
you'll be released without cash bail
Tammy Bruce host get Tammy Bruce on Fox
nation she joins us tonight Tammy thanks
so much for coming in here
so my pleasure of all the things to
worry about I'm sure people will say why
should I care if a bodega gets robbed
I guess the much bigger concern is that
we're starting to see the society fray
and from there things can can move
really quickly in the wrong direction
are you concerned about that well yes so
I've stayed in Manhattan through this
process and it is very eerie because one
of the things that makes you feel safe
in Manhattan especially as a woman is
that there are so many people on the
street well that of course is over now
so there's a general sense of foreboding
when you do go out really at any point
because there's really no one around
everyone's that you know maybe they're
jogging or getting some fresh air
walking their dog but very few people
also several hundred NYPD officers of
course have been stricken these are its
course it's an equal opportunity dynamic
so you have fewer police we've got the
National Guard coming in but it's going
to be mostly for medical so in the midst
of these neighborhoods we already
already have a shop sandboarding
themselves up anticipating this dynamic
and then you have the release it's not
just that the no bail law which has been
awful releasing criminals with you know
no real repercussions for certain kinds
of crimes but now they've got a list of
individuals they've already released
about 900 from people from Rikers Island
and other jails who they feel a
particular at risk for the virus now
look if you're non-violent he said it
would be nonviolent people to be
released so that there's fewer people
getting sick but ABC News received a
list that actually included violent
offenders awaiting trial
the
New York Post reports on a 63 year old
man awaiting trial for attempted murder
who was released because he may be at
higher risk the two men involved in an
armed robbery where a police and New
York police detective was was killed
we're also on the list to be released so
you've got they tell you there's
nonviolent offenders being released but
that is not true
finally prosecutors had to intervene so
New Yorkers are the first victims here
it has nothing to do with politics I
mean I'm sure they voted for many of
these politicians who are making these
choices and then and then we all in our
neighborhoods have to worry about the
nature of whether or not there's we're
going to be safe because of the previous
decisions the bad policy decisions that
both Albin Albany New York and Cuomo has
made as well as de Blasio and we see our
lives kind of crumbling within a social
structure and safety framework and
that's the last thing we need right now
obviously I mean it just takes hundreds
and hundreds of years to build a society
this functional this complex this clean
this orderly just happy and it can go
south really fast and I just hope that
we appreciate that Tammy or above you're
brave for staying there and we
appreciate the update tonight from my
pleasure this is a great city it's worth
saving